cardigan really skin
can we get makeup please to be great all
right guys let's go again
so this is awesome you seem great you
too and I love this place it is so clean
hey Britney [ __ ] I am so excited we are
gonna be best friends
did you see that face she me I am NOT
here to make friends
she better watch herself
you know I'm just exploring other
options yeah yeah hey Tyler I used to
live Americanos but now I'm all about a
lot of tips okay hey you guys know each
other yeah really well
oh hey were you done with this oh that's
not like weird thanks for doing the
dishes yeah oh hey um is this your wine
glass no it's not mine
are you kidding me did that wine glass
just like magically appear there I only
know one person who drinks that she
passed Merlot and she's about to get
what's coming to her we really need to
do this more often guys are the best
hold okay great job ladies Jess I'm glad
you're having such a good time since you
were worried that Emily never has
anything intelligent to say Mary let's
not forget the Justice League neither
husband and Brittany let's not forget
that Emily said that you were gaining so
much weight
don't let that ruin your evening let's
go again and remember your best friend's
rolling we should really do this more
often you guys are that bad
Carrie
we got it cut to the N cards cut to them